bring in the Warriors executive special
advisor and of course the Hall of Famer
Jerry joins us know good morning Jerry
how are ya
I find that how are you this morning I'm
great I was wondering about the whole
topic of three-pointers in the NBA would
you have wanted to had a three-point
line when you played well obviously it
would have helped me Dan there's no
question it would have helped me because
I think the way that the game was then
you know there's a really a lot of hand
checking I'm not talking about one hand
he almost feel like you had a steering
wheel here with the way the game was
played in the way the game was
officiated and I think it made a little
bit easier to get the other components
of your game going driving you know
getting to the basket a lot easier if
the threat of a three-point shot was
there but players would have to honor
that and give you a little bit more room
and they couldn't afford to just grab
and hold so it will open up the floor a
little bit more and I think it would
have been a good thing but now when you
see I think of one game this year was 55
three-point shots taken that's not a lot
of three-point shots because I just
don't think all those thoughts are
quality shots and I think it's because
this game is designed to to be a pretty
game kind of dust so to speak with
passing cutting and now you just see
guys one down one on five one on four
and I know the analytical people gotten
involved how much more valuable a shot
but I've always felt that when team
played really well together the quality
to show up is what matters most but can
you see a point Jerry where it is
cyclical where all of a sudden the big
man comes back in where you know Shaq
said he wouldn't have changed his game
he would still be a dominating force
there you know but do you see where we
will have that inside play and it'll be
important or more important than it is
now well I think you look look at what
the colleges are putting out the product
they're putting out it was really very
reminiscent of the NBA today
Steph Curry of all these players that
can shoot the ball really really well
from distance those other players that
these young kids are copying today and
in the ball handling ability the other
thing that is really that I think is
remarkable if you looked at Eastern
Conference Finals and it tells you about
scouting the number one player taken in
the draft was a bond James and they were
competing against the Boston Celtics in
the Eastern Conference Finals who was
Boston best player the number 16th
player taken in the draft Isaiah Thomas
45 8 look what it's done for these young
kids out there to his side this is going
to promote more people like that because
that gives him the ability because how
clever he is how he's used to ball from
distance and amazing how he finishes
around the basket for someone that size
that gives players and kids who love to
watch the game because so fun to watch
if they don't have the ability to go
ahead and run and dunk the ball which
every kid oh I dumped this age in my
wife which seems to be a kind of growing
up point point for young kids if they
don't have that ability in a tiny or
smaller they can still go compete
because that's three-point line lesson
played a game the way we were seeing it
evolve today but I do think the game can
go through cycles you know everyone gets
enamored with the incredible skill and
talent LeBron James but look at look at
the size that he has look at the skill
that he has look how hard he works in
the game and you look at Steph Curry who
physically you know he's he's gifted but
he's not that explosive side pull here
but look how great he's been and so I
think every generation of players every
generation of the game you're going to
see a constant and all of people being
involved in the kind of players that
they're watching when they're young but
there's still a place for the big guy
but he's still going to have to be a
little bit more versatile and some of
the older centers that's for sure
is it fair to compare players I know we
love to do it but can you compare LeBron
to Michael Jordan given that they played
in different eras oh my goodness yes you
know I look at the totality as work and
you know I think when you put the
greatest of all time right at the top of
the list Michael Jordan combines some
elements that I haven't seen in a
basketball player but I think the thing
that stands out to me and I've always
probably felt that the players who who I
like the best are well-rounded players
now not if they score the ball and they
don't do anything else I'm probably not
going to be as big a fan as those those
kind of players as players who play an
all-around game the totality of his game
is enormous people because Michael had
that swagger you know he had that killer
look in his face of someone who I
greatly admire LeBron James in his own
right you could put him up there
adjacent him everyone thought well look
how many rings Michael won I think
that's the craziest way to try to
compare a player that you possibly have
I'll take two players that in this
league Karl Malone and John Stockton -
great great great players and they did
it on both ends of the court they never
want to championship why couldn't people
like that be included it area they just
didn't have enough people around them to
make them win and all these all these
players that have played and won a lot
their totality their game had to be
enormous to help win those championship
but you have to look at the people they
played with my goodness
some of the greatest players ever played
and I just think it's unfair to try to
compare players who come on James seven
straight finals okay and in Miami he had
really great players he had he'd and
Dwyane Wade and Chris Bosh is really a
good player but I didn't feel that he's
in their caliber
but with them he was just better with
them because he would when he was in
Toronto he didn't have the same
supporting cast and he played his fanny
off there but he didn't have the same
supporting cast and that supporting cast
is what's going to get you to the very
zenith and in terms of winning
championships I know guys who won four
or five championships never got off the
bench and does that make them great
players and know the people who lifted
the bulk of the weight were the ones
that got him there he's Jerry West the
Lakers Hall of Famer special advisor to
the Golden State Warriors would you have
any trepidation if you had the chance to
select Lanza ball because he was dead
you know I really don't want to get into
that there's obviously players there
that that frankly I don't even like to
talk about his dad okay I'd rather talk
about the kid his dad to me I wouldn't
want a father like that to be honest
with you and because I think he puts an
added pressure on each kid you know he
loves these kids okay you know that even
but it just should be about his kids not
about him and you know the Lakers were
probably in a position are they going to
draft him that's up to them I think
there's three or four players in this
draft that I really like a lot
personally and to me they got a big
decision to make and whether they make
it four because of the because of his
father being from Los Angeles and saying
he wants to play here in Los Angeles I
wouldn't let a father in influence who
are after death by that would be for
sure
I would want I want to I would want to
player that I felt was the best player
at that position because when you're
drafting that position you can't not
afford to miss you cannot afford it
particularly the Lakers at this point in
time as they're trying to build depth
and a roster they're trying to get to
another level right now so this is
imperative for them to take the right
player if that's a little ones of all
that they're going to take him I know
you love your job but it still bothers
me that you're not with the Lakers it
does Jerry it does does it bother you at
all
Oh Dan obviously you know as I say I
think sometimes
your life when you reflect back in your
life I realized how fortunate I was to
work work play for the Lakers I coach
the Lakers and also be involved with the
late Jerry Buss those were the most well
special times in my life and I think it
probably is something that I remember
when I started as a player scared to
death I wouldn't even fit in and didn't
know that was good enough to play the
NBA level and suddenly playing with
someone like Elgin Baylor who really
helped my confidence early age in my
life and going on to have a career that
that I'd ever dreamed possible then have
an opportunity to coach a team and then
and then have an opportunity to work
with Jerry and the Lakers I felt very
much like I was early in the player as a
player where I was didn't know if I
would be good enough to do something but
I was incompetent enough to do something
and Jerry had faith in me to allow me
the opportunity to become an executive
and mean we as the Lakers had a lot of
success and everyone obviously when you
have success once the pass around
congratula way things and all this guy
did this this guy did that I never
looked at myself that way I can truly
say that then to me this is basketball
was love of my life it still is it's the
only thing I've ever put that got me out
of what I wouldn't wish on when anyone
when I was growing up and I loved Lakers
okay
and it's a different situation now a
different time and obviously I wish
everyone well oh and my son works there
I'm very proud that he works there and I
sometimes I thought in my life that
maybe that might be something that I can
revisit or they would want me to revisit
but that that didn't happen and had to
say at times I don't say I was
disappointed but you know it kind of
sent me a message and that you know they
wanted to go elsewhere which is fine and
but to say that I wouldn't have liked it
and in my career there
that wouldn't necessarily be curator
could you work for the Clippers in the
same building could I work for the
Clippers in the same building that's a
good question because they you know I've
always tried to do things under the
Nagus in a visible kind of way obviously
sometimes I wish my name was Jerry West
I wish I could just be a normal person
walk down the street and have fun with
my friends and people I enjoy being
around that hasn't been the case in my
life and I will tell you I had a very
intriguing meeting with the Clippers
Steve Ballmer is going to be a
sensational owner but that I'm 79 years
old okay and I I know how much that I
value the game of basketball I know what
it's done for me and I'm still really
competitive I'm just not so sure that
that anywhere is a good fit for me and
so in the process of you know talking to
people obviously it's going to get in
the newspaper and I don't like it that's
gotten in the newspaper and particularly
don't like it that because we're playing
in the finals and it shouldn't be a
distraction and I don't think it will be
by the way I'm more concerned about
going up to Oakland tonight and watch
the Warriors play and hopefully win this
game tonight then all the other noise
that's out there about me possibly
coming down here I just I just don't
want to talk about to be honest with you
well I hope you enjoy the process
watching the NBA Finals I note we used
to drive you crazy when you were the GM
but hopefully you're enjoying a little
bit of this and now safe travels up to
Oakland tonight cheering well thank you
Dan you know as I say this has been a
special place for me up there the
players we have up there you couldn't
find I forget their skill and talent
it's nice and good people I've ever been
around in my life and it's just a
pleasure for me to see something come to
fruition like the last three years and
it's been fun I'm hopeful that everyone
can achieve your goals and let's hope
it's the Warriors that prevail this year
well a belated Happy Birthday and
safe travels Gerry thank you again back
here dad that's Jerry West the Laker
hall-of-famer the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience